good evening members and officers of the
council and members of the press and
probably I welcome you to this meeting
of the council if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices at
where the stairs either through the
security doors to my right or opposite
the lifts in the foyer please do not use
the lifts please assemble in holy square
on the brain officers will assist you
and advise you when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber the Proceedings of
this meeting will be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet I
would advise that if filming takes place
anyone in attendance in the public areas
who may have their image captured
I urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
does anyone intend to film a meeting any
member of the public who objects to the
possibility of being filmed may wish to
take this opportunity to leave the
meeting any filming or recording will
not be permitted for any item of
business where exempt or confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the press and public from
the meeting
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls in the
chamber whilst this meeting is in
progress
agenda item 1 apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councillors current Martin and townand
are there any other apologies penciling
coleman cook thank you I attended item 2
minutes of the previous meeting held on
the 8th of February 2018 I move that the
minutes of the meeting of the Council
held on the 8th of February 2018 be
approved and signed as a correct record
with the vice chairman please second
second in madam chairman don't members
agree thank you announcements I have not
been informed of any announcements
agenda item for declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
councillor Dexter yes madam chairman I
wish to declare an interest in agenda
item 6a 6b 6b and 7a is because I'm the
governor of the East End hospitals trust
right thank you
those agenda items I will
sometimes we do yeah does he need to
when those dick decorates the interest
madam chairman I am also a member of the
hospital governing body and trust but I
shall not believe in the beating
otherwise I get asked a question all
right
members if I'm just give some advice
about those two declarations of interest
whilst while some wave made those
clearly we are making a decision it's
not a decision making a part of the
committee therefore I don't think it's
necessary for you to actually leave the
meeting cancelled Exeter or or Castle
wells
well carry on agenda item five petitions
one petition has been received and one
petition returns to Council in
accordance with council procedure rule
number 12 agenda item 5a petition
regarding Broadstairs toilet
refurbishment an e petition containing
69 valid signatures has been received by
the council I am pleased to welcome mr.
Ervin to the meeting could you please
make your way to the top table you have
up to three minutes to speak it's not
all right
no yeah in accordance with the council's
petition scheme the petition will be
referred to cabinet without debate for
reports of the council within three
ordinary meetings council currently
counsel messenger council messenger
Thank You chairman I just before it gets
actually processed to the cabinet you
might want to just correct the typo in
2.1 where it should say I believe three
hundred and fifty thousand not 350
thank you
agenda item five point the petition
regarding Western under cliff facilities
report back to the council this item is
to report back to the council's response
to the petition in accordance with the
council's petition scheme would members
please note the report Thank You agenda
item six questions from the press and
public for questions have been received
from members of the public in accordance
with council procedure rule number 13
please note that only the questioner and
respondents are permitted to speak on
the question and that if the questioner
is not present at this meeting
their question cannot be put but will be
replied to in writing could the
questioner please only state the name of
the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be fought and read out
the exact wording of the question that
they submitted to the council would
members please refer to the
supplementary agenda number one agenda
item 6a question number one from a
member of the Public Health Service
funding I am pleased to welcome dr.
Gordon Nesbitt to the meeting could you
please make your way to the top table
it's a question for councillor Wells
does councillor Wells backed the plan to
make savings of four hundred and fifty
seven million pounds on health service
funding for Kent and Medway as part of a
sustainability and transformation plan
that seems to disadvantage the already
deprived people of Thanet I call upon
the leader to respond thank you for your
question dr. Nesbitt speaking strictly
first of all from the point of view of
fana District Council and you appreciate
this is not funded District Council's
business as such it is a matter for the
NHS having said that we already have a
cabinet Advisory Group specifically to
deal with these issues and the
sustainability and transformation plan
was discussed initially at the meeting
in December 2016 when the initial
consultations began whilst these widely
acknowledged that savings are are
required to be made by the way that the
NHS is being structured at the moment we
will always lobby to ensure that the
local residents of Thanet are not
disadvantaged by the changes that were
made having said all of that I would say
from a personal point of view and as it
was addressed to me as council wells or
than consensus leader the council we
actually have a situation where we have
a top-down transformation plan from my
government to a County Council both of
whom happen to be conservative in nature
looking to actually make sure savings
are made in all that you can earn some
of that money back for being good boys
and girls and making those savings it's
a rather bizarre way to go about things
and certainly it's causing some
destructive disruption and difficulty
across other organizations across these
Kent and in the hospital governing body
itself thank you
agenda item 6b question number 2 from a
member of the public QE q em services
I'm pleased to welcome mrs. Jefferies to
the meeting could you please make your
way to the top table
this is a question for councillor Wells
we're losing our emergency stroke unit
at QE q em mean that we're more likely
to lose our ane as well as a result of
the loss in KOA Jason C's has the
council investigated this possibility in
depth
Thank You missus Jeffrey the leader to
respond thank you for your question mrs.
Jeffrey we are in the middle of a
consultation on this particular topic
and I made reference in the last answer
to the fact that we have a cabinet
Advisory Group who look at these topics
in relation to what the impacts are
residents of the changes that take place
in the NHS and I've requested that a
response for the consultation on these
proposals for emergencies showing in it
should be something the capital advisory
group considers at its next meeting that
said if you look at the information
that's come out from the hospital trusts
and from the NHS units that are working
on the standard saleability
transformation plan that your question
says means as are we more likely to lose
our ane as a result of the loss
encourage agencies and the answer to
that would seem to be no for the
information is available because the
decision on whether or not the a and E
is here or at Canterbury or Ashford or
where else is more related to the two
options that we considered a
consultation later on this year
and early next year of how the three
hospitals are going to be structured
thank you gender item 6c question number
three from a member of the public
monster Airport I am pleased to welcome
mr. rates to the meeting could you
please make your way to the top table
my question is to the leader of the
council mr. wells has TDC explored and
exploited all avenues under its
abilities in the exploitation of
aviation use at mana stone thank you
Thank You mr. right I call upon the
leader to respond
Thank You a question mr. right and there
was like hoping for a peaceful evening
the situation really is pretty simple
and straightforward and I think it's
often forgotten the council does not own
the Manston airport site and as a result
it's legal parses curation on that site
are limited
the options are realistically to look at
whether or not a compulsory purchase set
of powers will be appropriate to achieve
their aim and to date as we're all well
aware the council has failed to identify
or find a suitable indemnity partner to
fund the purchase and operate the
airport the other options for that site
being used for aviation relate to either
direct sale and purchase between willing
buyer and seller and or something that's
known as a development consent order
which we are promised is going to be
happening very soon I'd have to say
again so are those things are outside of
the council's powers over there'll be a
constancy on them
our powers relate to compulsory purchase
and for that we need empty partner and
to date we haven't been able to identify
one that has the funds of the
willingness to do it thank you
agenda item 60 question number 4 from a
member of the public health and
well-being board and retention of local
health services I am pleased to welcome
mrs. furrows to the meeting could you
please make your way to the top table
good evening could I just point out that
I'm not quite sure why I've been called
missus Ference because it should be Miss
Ference so I don't know where that came
from
I'm not a missus and I have no intention
of being one I've got a question for
councillor Wales given that councillor
Wales has not attended any of the
bimonthly health and well-being board
meetings since November 2015 of which he
is one of just two TDC members what is
he doing to ensure that Thanet retains
its 14 remaining GP practices it's a any
department and its stroke service thank
you mister I call upon the leader to
respond thank you for your question miss
Varens the situation I think we've
already touched on on some of these
these answers in in the previous two at
the moment Fallot has 14 GP practices as
most you'll be aware the NHS is view of
what a GP practice should do and look
like is rather different to what perhaps
most of us would remember anticipate and
expect there are a variety of ways of
running TV practices being trialed
across Kent to three different versions
or whatever the most popular one one
that seems to have most NHS support is
the history view approach to life which
is tucked away as you know near
Whitstable currently planet GP practices
are trying to support each other in in
little groups and clusters rather moving
over to a full history view type
approach and that's something that has
both the a wealth of health and
well-being and the CCG locally support
and they are co-located in the building
and the fact that we're not always at
the public meetings doesn't mean that
we're not talking to them cause
to me because we are and even then the
cabinet member responsible for those
areas the deputy leader and then
Fairbrass has been at all those meetings
representing our view the A&E department
is as I say subject to a decision from
the hospital trust in terms of what is
going to do with its three particular
sites and how and where any will be
distributed across very the East Kent
district and as we know a lot of that
quickly depends on what happens with the
strength and the ability of the
Canterbury campaign to actually overturn
decisions made some 20 years ago about
trying to make sure the services were
near where people most needed them
rather than where it's convenient for
the consultants who living can't agreed
to go to work and the stroke services
subject to a current consultation and as
I'll answer previously we will be as a
capital advisor group asking them to
actually formulate an appropriate
response for us in this council in the
very near future
could I ask why you haven't attended the
meetings thank you
[Applause]
questions from members of the council
there are two questions from councillors
both of which you've been withdrawn
agenda item 8 motions on notice no
motions on notice have been received in
accordance with council procedural 3
agenda item 9 leaders reports would
members please note that this item has
been withdrawn from the agenda
agenda item 10 reports of the count of
the council of the overview sorry
report to the chairman of the overview
and scrutiny panel
I call upon councillor David Saunders to
present his report Thank You chairman
this report is very short and it hasn't
been withdrawn the the overview and
scrutiny panels met on two occasion will
perhaps it should have been on two
occasions since my last report and the
papers before you this evening detail
the work of the subcommittee's that are
involved and since its publication the
Community Safety Partnership
subcommittee met on Tuesday of this week
and I have to say as I've said in
previous meetings I will wish that more
members would look at the agendas to see
what the subjects are because that these
subcommittees there are many many agenda
items which should be of interest to all
members on Tuesday we had an update from
Kemp police regarding the impact to
policing in parts of Ramsgate and
Margate which was very well received and
more importantly and I know this affects
all ward councillors we had a
presentation of the proposed new
arrangements that we're making and this
thanks again from Trevor Kenneth
excellent presentation new arrangements
that were making with regards to Tek or
attempt to tackle parents parking at
schools and the inconvenient parking an
inconsiderate parking that goes with
that very well received very good report
we're looking forward I'm sure all
members are looking forward to the
implementation of this proposal it will
be very well received and I'm sure it
will relieve a lot of wall councillors
from many many phone calls that they
receive with issues that they're unable
to tackle because they come under a
different authority so very very
short report both in your papers and in
my verbal dialogue but I commend the
report to counsels and I'm prepared to
answer questions should you have any
thank you
Thank You councillor Saunders thank you
very much chairman and thank you
councillor Saunders I'm very grateful to
mr. Kenneth for the report because I
discussed some of it with him earlier in
the day when we had another meeting it's
really important from a community safety
point of view that it's not just parking
that we address outside schools some
members will be aware of difficulties
particularly with speeding cars people
jumping lights it's in Gregory's school
I never miss an opportunity to raise
this because KCC and police and others
will only specifically deal with things
when there's a fatality at least one
they probably like to have more if so
they can deal with problems apparently
but it's really good that this council
is attacked tackling the parking side of
it but I hope that it's a joint
Community Safety effort outside our
schools and quite particularly sent
Gregory's that I've been dealing with
really since I was the leader in 2014
and I raised it every time and I don't
seem to get very far with it but this is
a start
thank you and it was also helpful to
have somebody in a motorbike going
around schools but it's a major major
issue and I raised it all the time so
I'm doing it tonight in front of all of
you so people don't forget when I'm long
gone thank you
[Applause]
counselor brim as cabinet member of
operational services I actually put it
to the director that it is within Sanok
District Council's ream it's to actually
put CCTV cameras outside schools which
would permanently deal with the issue
running campaigns is okay but it's a
sticking-plaster and everything will go
back to normal in matter of time now
this is a priority children's lives are
a priority safety is a priority I've
tried to ensure that outside our local
secondary school with delivering 160,000
pounds worth of puffin crossings but
outside these schools it is a problem
and I feel in at the schools where it is
an issue and it's been raised and
highlighted we need to put permanent CCC
needs to be addressing the issue thank
you
agenda item 11 council tax resolution
2018 19 would members please refer to
the supplementary agenda number 27
oh sorry number 2 it's a toilet question
mark it was like seven supplementary
agenda at number two I would advise
letting in accordance with council
procedure rules seventeen point six I
will call for a recorded vote on the
motion or any amendments and substance
stunts live emotions
I call upon counselor it's too much
spacing thank you Jim this report sets
out the calculation of Thanet council
tax and proposes the increase to be
effective for 2018-19
it includes reference to the preceptors
listed in paragraph four one point three
point eight and one point three point
nine whose precepts TDC collect along
with its own council tax council
approved the 2018-19 budget on the 8th
of february which assumed an increase of
6 pounds 57 for a pan band d property
this represents an increase of two point
nine nine percent I would like to draw
members attention to the relatively low
increase in thanasis council tax
increase as shown in paragraph 2.3 it is
below the overall increase of five point
two four percent and only Kent Fire and
Rescue as a smaller increase than TDC
this report in its recommendations
follow a structure as laid down in law
and it represents a statutory resolution
I move the recommendation
is there a second
okay I instruct the monitoring officer
to conduct the recorded role Thank You
chairman councillor Ashby sorry thank
you and in all my time here the leading
group on council would make
representations to government about the
dire straits that this council might
find itself in even when things weren't
so bad we would make an effort to let
government know how difficult it was for
us and in recent years it's been worse
than ever I think it's a 43 percent
damage done to this council
so what representations has the leader
or councilor tone and/or the relevant
officers I really do appreciate the hard
work I tell you this all the time but I
really appreciate but what
representations were made to government
the government obviously our
Conservative government thank you we
take every opportunity to remind the
higher tier authorities at the meetings
when we deal with things like the
business rates pooling and then we deal
with government ministers and d-h CLG to
actually point out that we are suffering
we are finding life extremely difficult
I have said over and over again in this
chamber and outside if you go back to
the financial year 2012 we have an
income in this council of somewhat in
excess of 21 and a half million pounds
of which 11 million came from government
funds by 1920 we'll be living on an
income of 16 1/2 million pounds all of
which has to be raised locally
government does know exactly what the
situation is it has probably cut local
government harder than any other part of
the public estate during the course of
the years of what's become known as the
years of austerity they do know what the
situation is and we do tell them all the
time we do remind them but they seem
intent on this particular road and
pushing us into evermore increasingly
difficult financial decisions many of
which you will have
and heard over recent years thanks so
cancel Ashby
Tessa Bainbridge that's AB a furred Casa
Braidwood Casa brim Casa Buckley
Catholic amble cats a Keith Coleman cook
Catholic honor
Casa Constantine Casa crow Brown cathode
Orson Castle a day
not here
Casa della Casa Dennis Gossard Dexter
Casa Dixon Casa Edwards Castle Evans
Casa Jeremy Fairbrass castle in
Fairbrass Casa Falcon Casa Fenner castle
a game counselor Gregory Casa Grove Casa
hatin castle Hillman Casa house Casa Jay
Jones castle Johnston castle Hawkins
counselor matter face counselor
messenger Casa Parsons Casa Linda Piper
councillor Stewart Piper counsel Linda
pots counselor Roy pots counselor pew
counselor Rogers casa rosa key
councillor David Saunders castle amaze
Saunders castle a savage katha sönke
castles Thomas Merton Council a Taylor
councillor Taylor Smith councillor
Tomlinson council Venables
Castle wells council tax resolution is
passed thank you agenda item 12
standards hearing decision counts labrum
I call upon the monitoring officer Thank
You chairman I think it is important
they introduced the report and
particularly explain what counsel are
being asked to do tonight and also what
counsel are not being asked to do the
report asked council to consider a vote
of censure in relations accounts of
brimm a vote of censure it's a formal
expression of severe disapproval or a
reprimand this relates to counts of
brims use of social media in a way which
compromised the integrity of an officer
and through the action council brim
brought her office and her council into
disrepute tonight the council is not
able to review or change that the
decision of the standards hearing
subcommittee which is already decided
that council brim has breached the code
of conduct and member of the protocol
Nori's council able to change the
sanctions imposed and councillor prim as
a response to her breach of the code of
conduct council is simply being asked to
implement one of the three sanctions and
agree a vote of censure the breach of
the code of conduct centers around
councillor brims posts on her Facebook
page in that post she said that a named
officer needs to go and the officer was
not fit for purpose it is a
long-standing tradition in public
service the remember should not raise in
public matters related to the conduct or
capability of an officer the member
officer protocol says that members
should be aware that officers are
constrained in the response that they
may make to public comments from members
members should not criticize officers
personally in public or through the
press nor seek to undermine their
position by abuse rudeness or ridicule
when those comments came to light
counselor brim was immediately asked to
remove them from Facebook but she
refused to do so I should also add the
castle brim has recently repeated those
comments in an email to all members
so to recap in terms of the council's
role today councillor brim has been
convicted and sentenced in respect to
the breach of the Code of Conduct the
council today is being asked to carry
out part of that sentence by expressing
their disapproval through a vote of
censure thank you Thank You councillor
Piper thank you madam chair
I just wonder if I might ask mr. house
through through your chair please for
just one more piece of clarity he's been
kind enough to answer a number of emails
for me this week in the main paragraph
it says essentia is the issue of an
unfavorable opinion or judgment or
reprimand just for clarity are those
three things all the same thing with a
different title or are they three
different forms of censure and if they
are three different forms of censure
could we have some guidance as to which
one is intended to be used Thank You Cho
know what you're considering today is a
form of censure and those words that I
mentioned earlier the favorable opinion
or judgment our reference are merely a
description to say you understand what
the word sense you're means so it means
a form of reprimand or a favor opinion
or judgment
I propose that the council sensuous
councillor bring for her behavior in
using social media in a way which
compromised the impartiality or
integrity of an officer and in bringing
her office and the council into
disrepute would the vice chairman please
second I second that madam chairman do
members agree thank you
all those in favor no somebody said a
show of hands yeah
so I asked I think there was a
suggestion that there ought to be in a
formal show of hands in which case the
Chairman's asked me to do that so
complete have a show of hands all those
in favor of a vote of censure please
the moment the motion is passed the Sun
sure is past
those who didn't vote that concludes the
business for the meeting of the council